llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en france24 salud a mi compañero jorge
hurtado especialista en la materia jorge
vamos a comenzar con datos del comercio
de américa latina y el caribe comercio
internacional así que juan qué gusto
saludarte bueno según la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe conocida como cepal el incremento
proyectado es de 25 por ciento en el
valor de las exportaciones regionales de
bienes específicamente pero esto se ve
amenazado por un contexto de
incertidumbre como la pandemia y los
riesgos del sector inmobiliario de china
el organismo afirma que este crecimiento
es impulsado por el alza el 17 por
ciento de los precios de exportación y
una expansión del 8 procedente en el
volumen en la región es américa del sur
que registraría el mayor aumento del
valor exportado en 2021 con un 34 por
ciento porque se verá beneficiado de los
mayores precios en las materias primas
también el valor de las exportaciones
mexicanas crecería un 17% y una
situación parecida se observa en
centroamérica en el caribe se esperan
que países como guyana trinidad y tobago
y jamaica se beneficiarán de los altos
precios del petróleo y el gas el valor
de las importaciones de bienes
aumentaría un 32% como resultado de una
expansión del 20 por ciento de su
volumen y de un 12% de sus precios entre
los principales socios comerciales juan
de la región específicamente
latinoamérica los flujos con asia
mostraron un aumento del 35% en el valor
de las exportaciones a china así como
dentro de la propia región en este
informe de la cepal también hay una
referencia a los costos de los envíos de
los fletes y también a la crisis de
suministros así es bueno como sabrán
desde mediados de 2020 el año en que la
pandemia afectó la economía el costo de
los fletes comenzó a aumentar por
ejemplo en febrero de 2021 el costo
promedio de transportar un contenedor de
40 pies fue un 240 por ciento más alto
que en febrero de 2020 en 2019 el
promedio de los fletes a nivel mundial
fue de 1.457 dólares equivalente a 40
pies pero a partir de julio de 2020 el
valor sobrepasó los 2 mil dólares y en
octubre de este año alcanzó alcanzó los
10 mil 361 dólares esta cifra juan es
600 16 por ciento más alta que él mes de
2019 el informe de la cepal indica que
los fletes en la ruta que une asia con
la costa este de américa del sur
alcanzaron un mil 400 por ciento más en
12 meses del año se cumplen tres meses
desde que el salvador adoptó el bitcoin
como una moneda de curso legal jorge
como les ha ido bueno fue
específicamente el 7 de septiembre que
inició esto hace tres meses y este
periodo ha estado marcado por una baja
aceptación entre los salvadoreños así
como denuncias de falta de transparencia
en el manejo de los fondos estatales
pero el entusiasmo oficial es tal el
presidente nadie buque le anunció la
construcción de una bitcoin city una
ciudad donde no se pagarán impuestos a
excepción del impuesto del 10 por ciento
del iva y el gobierno emitirá bonos
bitcoin por 10 mil millones de dólares
esto opina ricardo castanea él es
economista del instituto centroamericano
de estudios fiscales escuchamos
un experimento porque
requiere toda una arquitectura
institucional para echarlo a andar y yo
creo que uno de los puntos que no se
debe de pasar de vista es cómo va a
reaccionar el sistema financiero
tradicional ante esto a mí me parece
sumamente grave lo que se ha anunciado
con el bitcoin citi porque básicamente
es una zona económica especial donde se
van a establecer incentivos fiscales al
eterno esto significa que mientras una
empresa o un inversionista está ahí
nunca va a pagar impuestos de américa
latina' nos vamos a medio oriente porque
hay un cambio en los días de la semana
laboral en emiratos árabes unidos- de
qué se trata cuando hasta ahora allí se
trabajaban cuatro días y medio y
comenzaba el domingo y terminaba el
jueves ahora trasladarán su fin de
semana los audios los domingos con el
fin de mejorar la competitividad según
dijeron las autoridades con este cambio
iniciará que el iniciar el primero de
enero se oponen a la norma regional de
un día libre completo el viernes para
las oraciones musulmanas y se convierten
en el único país del golfo que no tienen
un fin de viernes a sábado está por
verse si el sector privado se suma a la
iniciativa escuchemos qué opinan los
trabajadores
creo que ahora estamos en la línea de
los mercados internacionales y al estar
en el sector financiero marca la
diferencia porque te da un día más para
hacer las respuestas las tareas y demás
así que creo que es bueno desde el punto
de vista internacional
no trabajamos los viernes y los clientes
extranjeros no trabajan los domingos por
lo que hay un intervalo de unos tres
días antes de que nos sincronizamos así
que el tiempo de sincronización con
nuestros clientes y proveedores
extranjeros ha aumentado recibimos con
satisfacción el cambio por resultado con
la información económica quédense en la
pantalla de france 24
[Música]